good enough
is great
perhaps not a concept you'd expect to
hear
at the business school
yet this notion of good enough is great
underlies a lot of our entrepreneurial
efforts
the concept of minimally viable product
design
is critical for bringing products to
market
in this approach
you strive to get your product or
service out there quickly
so that you can test and get feedback to
see where the true value lies
let me give you an example
imagine you're a baker and you want to
bring
your baked goods to the broad market you
have visions of crafting wonderful cakes
and pies to delight your customers
minimally viable product design mvp
would suggest that rather than starting
with elaborate cakes
you start by making cupcakes
cupcakes provide
good value to your potential clients
they're relatively easy to make and they
allow you to solicit feedback to better
understand how you can hone and develop
your products and services
for the future
this notion of minimally viable product
design is critical to your success
in growing your product and services
it comes down to five key steps
understanding the user requirements
the problem space or market that you're
trying to deliver in
the metrics you'll use to assess
the success of your offering
you create designs
really quick product versions to bring
to the market and then you test
and you iterate
fundamentally the concepts involved in
mvp
are things like prototyping
understanding the needs and iteration
all to drive you towards value
the key idea here in our talk today
is this fundamental belief
that the ideas in minimally viable
product design
translate into our communication
so i'd like to welcome you to a talk on
minimally viable communication
when good enough
is great
my name is matt abrahams i've been here
at the stanford graduate school of
business for over a decade teaching
strategic communication skills and i am
thrilled to share with you ways that we
can use principles
from minimally viable product design to
apply to our communication
much like there were five steps in the
mvp process
we have five steps in the mvc process
it starts by looking at your audience
understanding who they are and what they
need from your messaging you have to
appreciate the context in which you're
communicating
create a goal that is very specific for
that audience in context
structure and design out your
communication
and then solicit feedback
and iterate
so let's get started and understand each
of these key components
it all begins
with your audience
who are you speaking to
and more importantly
what are their needs
many of us when we communicate make a
fundamental mistake and we start from a
position of here is what i want to say
rather than what does my audience need
to hear
now this sounds like verbal jujitsu
where i'm just moving words around but
it is a fundamental difference in our
approach
we need to understand our audience and
what they need to hear from us
so there's several questions i would
like for you to think about when you
have a important communication to craft
first and foremost what does my audience
know
about my topic do they know a lot or do
they know a little
we have all been victimized by
communicators who start too high level
or too low level for us
second you need to think about their
attitudes relative to the topic that
you're discussing are they in favor
perhaps they're not in favor of what
you're saying or maybe they're agnostic
they just don't know enough
you also have to think about resistance
points
what are the things that might cause
hesitation in your audience
is it what you're proposing costs too
much money takes too much time requires
too much effort
we have to think about knowledge
attitudes and resistance
and from my colleagues here at the
business school we add
psychological distance
how far are you away from your audience
not physical distance but perhaps in an
organization are you much more senior or
perhaps more junior to the person
talking that matters in terms of what
you say and how you say it according to
research from near halevi
research from zac tormela tells us we
have to understand the relevance and
importance of what we're saying so that
we can motivate and influence our
audience
so thinking through our audience is the
first step
in the minimally viable communication
process
and this can go badly in fact let me
give you an example
there is a durable goods company in
northern europe called electrolux and
many years ago they ran this ad campaign
nothing sucks like an electrolux
this ad was an abysmal failure
why
we don't like to buy things that suck
you can imagine some advertising person
in their office thinking i know we're
going to suggest that our vacuum cleaner
suction is so powerful that it caused
the tower of pisa to lean
but they didn't understand their
audience
down to the linguistic level
nothing sucks like an electrolux so we
have to take the time as part of our
design process
to think through our audience
at many levels including linguistic
now let me share an example of where
understanding your audience actually was
very helpful and i borrowed this story
from where i first read it in the book
made to stick by dan and chip heath and
chip teaches here at the business school
and in this inmate district they
described the story of texas
in texas in the mid 1980s there was a
huge littering problem
trash and rubbish all over the place
it didn't look good and it wasn't
healthy
so the government invested in a public
service campaign featuring this guy
and i know many of you listening in
today are of my vintage and you i might
remember woodsy the owl give a hoot
don't pollute and woodsy was placed on
billboards television and radio remember
this was the 80s there was no internet
when i share this story with my mba
students today they physically get
disturbed at the thought of no internet
something interesting happened though
after two years of woodsy being on
television radio
and billboards
littering got worse
it was as if texans were saying we don't
like you woody and they were throwing
more garbage all over the place
this caused great concern
so the government
invested in an effort to bring academics
in to help with the littering problem
and the very first thing the academics
did was try to figure out who is doing
the littering
now for some of you this might not be
surprising
it turns out that most of the littering
was being perpetrated by men
not just any men but men between the
ages of 18 and 34.
and they went further beyond learning
who was doing the littering they they
looked into some of the attitudes and
beliefs that these people held
and for any of you who have been to
texas or grew up in texas you know one
thing is true about texas males in that
age demographic
they are very proud of being from texas
if they could they would make texas its
own country
based on knowing who was doing the
litter in some of the attitudes they
created this ad campaign
and if you have been to texas you've
seen it it's still around today 30 years
later
don't mess with texas
it's a play on words don't mess meaning
literally don't make a mess
but also don't mess i take great pride
within two years of this ad campaign
coming out they were able to reduce
littering in the state to up to 80
percent
if you know anything about social
science research an effect size that
large is unheard of
by getting the right message to the
right people in the right way you can
have a huge
effect
the take home message here is take time
to know your audience it is the first
step in the minimally viable
communication process
but it's not enough just to know about
your audience you also have to think
about the context in which you are
communicating whenever you communicate
there's a context which includes many
things
cultural elements channel elements like
the technology you're using but i want
to highlight two that are critical for
bringing communication to your audience
the first has to do with the time of day
you're communicating
right now it's my morning for some of
you it's your early afternoon and for
others it's your evening
that impacts what you bring to our
communication your focus your
willingness to collaborate your
engagement
research by gsb professor baba shiv
looks at our neurochemical profile
depending on the time of day
in fact his research suggests if you're
looking for collaborative work it's best
to do it early in the morning
when people are more open to
collaboration based on dopamine and
serotonin levels
now that doesn't mean the only time to
collaborate is in the morning what it
means though is if you're doing it later
in the day
you might have to do some team building
and trust building activities first to
get people to that place of
collaboration
time of day matters when it comes to
your communication
another timing variable involved in
context is sequence
we often prepare our communication as if
it will be received in isolation
yet we all live lives where we realize
we are constantly bombarded with
different communication messages
think about the sequence of your
messaging where are you in the
interaction that your audience
experiences
think of it this way if you're proposing
a new plan that involves investment from
your organization and you're going into
the executive committee
following somebody who delivered bad
news
might that influence the decision-making
process
it could you need to think about that
sequencing similarly what could you do
to set up others who come behind you and
follow you in your communication
so context is equally critical to think
about
i recently heard this quote that i love
that really reinforces the value of
thinking about your audience
and your context
it goes something like this
writing a high-stakes communication
without thinking about your audience
is like writing a love letter and
addressing it to whom it may concern
you would never do that
nor should you draft high-stakes
communication without thinking about
your audience
and to that idea i add without thinking
about the context it's like taking that
love letter putting it in a bottle
throwing it in the ocean hoping it lands
in the right place you must equally
focus on your context
so the question becomes why and what's
next in the minimally viable
communication process once we think
about audience and context we have to
think about our goal
all high stakes communication must be
goal driven
and to my mind a goal has three major
components it's about information
emotion and action
in other words what do you want your
audience to know
how do you want them to feel
and what do you want them to do
no
feel do
your goal is predicated on what you know
about your audience in your context so
if the audience changes or the context
changes you might need to change your
goal
for this presentation i'm giving you
today my goal is quite simple
i'd like for you to leave here knowing
how minimally viable product design
processes
apply to your communication
further i'd like you to know the
specific steps in best practices in the
minimally viable communication process
i want you to feel confident in your
ability to apply these processes and
ultimately to put them into practice
whenever you're bringing messaging to
your audiences
know
feel
do
take the time to figure out your
communication goal
because this goal will come back to help
us later not only does it direct what we
want to say going forward
it also helps us assess our success
it is critically important
that you take time to understand what
the success of your communication would
look like
when i travel all over the world
teaching communication skills
i'll often ask
how do you know if your communication
was successful and the number one answer
i get is i got through it as if survival
is the key metric of success of course i
think that's ridiculous you should be
able to measure the success of your
messaging your communication based on
the goal you set out with
so a goal not only helps you
figure out what direction to take your
messaging it also helps you assess your
success
now once you have a goal in mind we then
have to spend time
ideating before we can create our
structure
we have to be inspired to think about
what are the key themes and ideas that i
want to get across
and this is where lessons from
stanford's d school design school can
really come in handy
there are myriad ways to get creative
in coming up with your ideas that will
feed into your messages
let me share a few that i like to use as
i'm creating my minimally viable
communication
first and foremost there's old-fashioned
brainstorming most of us have done that
where you just generate ideas without
bringing judgment to them at first it's
a good idea to give you some time
constraints research suggests time
constraints help with brainstorming
but other techniques work well too
one i'll often employ is to put myself
in a different perspective i'll ask
myself how would
a seven-year-old matt
address this issue
kids are wonderfully creative put
yourself in that creative playful
mindset and ask yourself how you would
approach this particular communication
challenge with the goal you have and
where would that lead
another way i like to bring brainstorm
or come up with ideas is to do a mind
map so rather than listing things out
which can lead to chronological bullet
point
ideas and results rather get graphic
draw circles and arrows and see if that
can help you come up with unique ideas
and perhaps my most favorite way of
generating ideas is one i recently
learned from a colleague at the d school
and that is using analogies
think about
situations that are similar to what
you're trying to communicate and what
could you learn by exploring those
different situations
let me give you two examples of what i
mean by this thinking in creativity
through analogy
there was a hospital chain
in the midwest that was interested in
improving their emergency room
results
and rather than going around to other
hospitals and checking their best
practices which i'm sure they likely did
they actually went to a formula one
pit crew and they observed what a pit
crew did to quickly get cars back out on
the race course
and if you think about it
a racing pit crew and what happens in
the er is really similar you've got time
critical sensitive urgent issues that
have to be fixed and resolved quickly
and they learn many things by looking at
how the pit crew function for example
most pit crews have kits set up for
different situations they might find
themselves in so let's say a tire blows
out they have a whole set of materials
set aside for dealing with that one
issue
the hospitals in their ers took that
idea and developed kits for the
different types of emergencies they
might see
another example is apple
when apple opened up its retail stores
they created the genius bars essentially
the tech support in the stores
rather than or in addition to looking at
top notches top-notch service
organizations they actually went and
explored how high-end hotel concierge
services worked
by using analogies
new ideas and approaches can come to
mind and this ideation can then help you
begin to create
your communication
so once you have your goal which is
based on your audience in context you
have to spend some time brainstorming
and coming up with the information that
you want to communicate that will help
you achieve your goal
once you have those ideas in mind you
have to crystallize them and bring them
into clear focus
and i love
the tool of six word stories to help
bring focus to your ideas
take all of the themes and the
creativity that you spent in the
ideation phase and try to distill them
down
in six words
and that six word narrative
becomes the driver
for the message design that you will
create this is a focusing activity
for this talk today
my six-word story is craft messages
for quick iterative feedback
that was the narrative i used to help me
structure this entire presentation
what's your six word story for the
messages you need to create
the next step in the minimally viable
communication process
once we've ideated and we've focused
is to structure our messages
structure is absolutely critical
for your communication
we have all been victimized by people
who ramble on and on i hope that's not
happening right now
when somebody is rambling it makes it
really challenging for us to focus
we have to bring a lot of energy to
focus and what most of us do is we check
out
so what is it
that we can do to make it easier for our
audience
and that thing
is to make sure
that you provide structure i learned
this a long time ago as an undergrad at
stanford i was a tour guide
and one of the number one things they
taught us as a tour guide on the
stamford campus
is never
lose your audience you are a bad tour
guide if you get people lost
how do good tour guides keep people
together
they set their expectations and that's
one of the powers of structure structure
sets your expectation
would any of you go on a tour with me if
i showed up and said hi i'm matt i'm
your tour guide let's go
some of you would because you're
adventurous but many of you would be
like heck no where are we going why are
we going there do i have the right shoes
on so by setting your expectations up
front by structuring your tour you can
relax and enjoy
the other value that structure brings
is structure helps
us
to remember the information that's being
communicated
neuroscientists tell us that structured
information is actually processed more
fluently and efficiently
think about this how many of you can
remember phone numbers from when you
were a kid
most of us can now my kids today they
don't have to remember phone numbers
they just look at a picture and push a
button on their phone and somebody else
starts talking
but in our day we had to remember phone
numbers here in the united states our
phone numbers are 10 digits long
it's hard to remember 10 digits if i
gave you 10 numbers right now and asked
you to remember them for an hour or a
day or a year or a decade or in my case
many decades that would be hard
so how do we do it
we leverage structure we don't remember
10 digits
rather here in the united states we
remember the three-digit area code the
three-digit prefix and the four-digit
number that structure helps us remember
so structure is something that can be
very useful to you as you communicate
so allow me to introduce you to one of
many structures and when it comes to
minimally viable communication i believe
this structure is perhaps the most
effective one you can use
and this structure is the what
so what
now what structure
let me explain it and then let me share
with you how you can use it
in this structure you start by talking
about what it is you are crafting it's
your message your idea your product your
service whatever it is you are
communicating
the so what is why is it important or
relevant to the audience that you are
speaking to
it could be to the audience directly it
could be to their company it could be to
society but it involves relevance
and then finally now what what comes
next
it has momentum built in maybe the next
step is to watch a demonstration to take
a taste of something
to set up a next meeting
what so what now what is a powerful way
of structuring your messages why
it's easy to remember you simply answer
the three questions and you get a
structure
second it has that relevance built in
and if something is relevant people will
pay more attention to it and they're
more likely to remember and act on
and it has that momentum that now what
step helping you understand
what to do after the message
so as you are quickly crafting your
content to bring to your audience to
iterate what so what now what is your
friend
i'd like to take a meta moment here a
time out in my mba classes
we do a lot of this meta moment stuff
why
it allows us to better understand our
communication and i just want to point
out
that i just explained what so what now
what
using what so what now what it's a
powerful concept for teaching
information
in fact everything i've shared today has
been packaged in this structure i tell
you what it is
why it's important and share with you
how you can best use it so i encourage
you
to once you've spent some time getting
creative ideating and focusing your
message
to think about how can i structure that
message to achieve that six word story
overarching approach that i have
the final phase
in our minimally viable communication
process
is to search for feedback
the whole goal of minimally viable
communication just like minimally viable
product design is to iterate you need to
test and get feedback so that you can
hone your messages
here you see on the screen
something i remember from a kid as part
of a science lab in elementary school we
had to build contraptions that would
allow an egg to fall from a rooftop
to the ground without cracking
and we tested a lot of different ideas
the winning idea was a parachute
strapped to the egg and that's what you
see here we have to test we have to
iterate we have to ask for feedback and
based on that feedback go through this
process again
and again until we have the message
honed in such a way that it can provide
the optimal value for our audience
the minimally viable communication
design process
can help you
in many if not most communication
situations
it starts by understanding your audience
their knowledge level their attitudes
their resistance points the
psychological distance between you and
them and the relevance and importance of
what you're saying to them
we have to think about the context which
includes many facets including timing
time of day and sequence
you have to spend time understanding
your goal know
feel do
and that goal allows you not only to
focus your messaging and efforts but it
also allows you to assess your success
in the final phase that feedback phase
and then we have to take the time to
structure but before we can structure we
have to ideate and focus
taken together
this process of minimally viable
communication design can help you get
meaningful messages to your audiences
very quickly to add value for you
and for them
if you'd like to learn more about
this type of communication or other
aspects of communication i'd like to
point you to a few resources
i've written a book called speaking up
without freaking out that can help you
feel more comfortable and confident in
your communication
i curate a website called
nofreakingspeaking.com where my research
and that of others is there for you to
check out and one of the
greatest pleasures of my life is i get
to host a podcast for the business
school called think fast talk smart
where if we do our job right we use
minimally viable communication to bring
relevant specific communication
tools and ideas to you from stanford
faculty mainly from the business school
i invite all of you to continue to
develop and hone your communication
skills
and remember
good enough is great and with that
i'd now like to take some time to listen
to your questions
and ideas around how to become a more
effective communicator alegria do we
have some questions that have come in
we do so i had a question come in asking
um
when it comes to leadership a lot of
leadership coaches have told us that
although leaders think that they have
explained enough their audience feel
that they have not received enough
communication
so how is this
how is that affected by a leader trying
to be minimally viable
yeah that's a i i appreciate the insight
motivating that question which is
minimally viable doesn't necessarily
mean less information
minimally viable simply means that
you're testing out your messages to
understand what's needed for your
audience so i actually think minimally
viable communication resolves the
problem that the questioner is asking
because as a leader if i have important
information to share
i go out and iterate and test my
messaging with some of the people in the
audience and understand am i saying
enough am i saying too much is there
more i need to bring
and that will help me hone my message
for the broader audience in other words
i make those cupcakes and i bring those
cupcakes to a few people in that
audience i get their taste test and
information and then i prepare myself to
bring the big sheet cake to everybody in
the audience so i actually think
minimally viable communication is the
solution to the problem that the
questioner was asking
our next question
is isn't the ted talk mentality an enemy
of your proposed approach
polished endlessly
rehearsed to the point of perfection
ah great i love i love i love the
challenge that this is bringing in so
when it comes to communication i
separate communication into two
different approaches one is the planned
communication and that's this ted talk
like approach where you plan you you
practice you you really try to dial in
the communication
and then there is the more spontaneous
communication
the communication that happens off the
cuff in the moment etc
and this approach this mental approach
minimally viable communication can play
out in both sections in both
approaches to your communication
clearly in the planned presenting you're
practicing you're iterating you're
getting feedback and you're leveraging a
lot of the tools that i mentioned in the
talk in a spontaneous speaking situation
again most of her communication you can
still leverage many of these principles
immediately think about your audience
and their needs consider the context
you're speaking in what is my goal in
this moment
and then structure messages to answer it
so the same process can apply in real
time
when the question i just answered came
in i immediately thought who am i
talking to i'm talking to a bunch of
alums from the business school i thought
about this context of it being virtual
and the situation where you're hoping to
learn something of value you can apply
and i immediately thought of my goal
what do i want you to know feel and do
as a result of my answer to your
question and that fed into the way i
answered it so in other words i imply i
applied these specific
processes i went through into how i
handled the spontaneous situation of
answering the question
so the the the answer boils down to
there are two fundamental different
types of communication spontaneous and
planned
and what we talked about applies to both
now i heard some value judgment in that
question which is isn't that ted talky
overly rehearsed scripted
approach
uh something that is not to be desired
in perhaps everyday business
communication and while i think at the
extremes that's probably true but the
notion of being planned prepared and
iterating i think can help for both
planned and spontaneous speaking
i think this might be related to what
you just said and you may have already
answered it but
how does the uh ideation iteration and
practice practice practice
affect authenticity
yeah
so authenticity is critical so when it
comes to
your presence it's really about
confidence
credibility and authenticity
and you want to walk that fine line of
being prepared but not being over
prepared
and that's why in the work i do here at
the business school in terms of the
strategic communication classes i i
teach in co-teach it's all about
teaching fundamental best practices
and giving students opportunities to to
explore and test those best practices
so that you can then
internalize what works for you so you
can develop your own style
i like to use the analogy from sports
all of us at some point in our life
learned how to swing some kind of
sporting implement a bat a club a racket
and we learned some foundational
principles that would help us be good at
doing that but if i were to look at any
of you swinging one of those implements
you would look slightly different than
the way i do it the way other people do
it based on your experience
your expertise your age your injuries
it is finding the foundational
principles and honing them for you that
leads to your authenticity
so these foundational principles that i
covered today audience context goal
ideation focus structure feedback
those foundational principles you have
to internalize
take
from different areas and different
experiences hone it for yourself and
that will allow you to be more authentic
as you deploy them
so i certainly don't want everybody to
speak the same way to structure messages
the same way but i do think there is
value by going through a fundamental
process to help you come up with those
messages i think that only bolsters your
authenticity rather than taking away
from it
great thank you we have a question here
asking what happens after mvc
how does one then do the full-on
communication ah thank you so
this is only the beginning this is to
help you figure out what to say you must
then focus on how you say it and you
have to focus on the channel through
which you deliver it
so we have to think first i have this
message what's the best way to get that
message to my audience is it a
multi-channel approach is it an
individual conversation or dialogue so
the next step is to think about how do i
deploy that message and again you can
iterate and test and figure that out and
then you also have to focus on your
non-verbal presence how do you actually
deliver the message you can have the
best well-crafted honed message but if
it's delivered poorly that can get in
the way so i'm going to wax poetic just
for a couple minutes because i have a
lot of thoughts on non-verbal presence
first
you have to make sure you are
comfortable and confident and some of
the resources i pointed to at the end of
what i said can help you in that way
there are many tools that you can use to
feel more comfortable and confident in
your communication and i encourage you
to take the time to work on that in all
the strategic communication classes here
taught here at the business school we
start with confidence building
once you have a foundational layer of
confidence level of confidence in what
you're doing you then have to think
about how you show up to deliver and i'd
like to give you three bits of advice
about your non-verbal presence
first is what you do with your body
there are three key concepts with your
body you want to be big you want to be
balanced and you want to be still
nervous people make themselves small
they retreat in person i step back
in a virtual world i sit far away so you
don't see my face as much we want to be
big and present a great way to help
yourself be big is simply to take your
shoulder blades your scapula bones and
your back and pull them down when i pull
them down towards my waist i get broader
now i'm not bringing my elbows back and
puffing out my chest rather i'm just
pulling those shoulder blades down that
helps me look big and confident
it also tightens up the muscles in my
neck so my head is straight many of us
tilt our heads and tilting your heads
when you're in one-on-one interaction
listening is actually a great thing to
do but when you're trying to command
confidence delivering an important
message you want your head to be
straight not tilted and this body
posturing will help and clearly shifting
and rocking and swaying can be very
distracting so big balanced and still in
terms of your body posture
the second thing to think about is eye
contact
in north american culture where i am
today eye contact is expected we expect
people to look us in the eye
when i'm in person i will segment my
audience instead of trying to look at
every person individually i'll create
quadrants and i'll look in the back part
of the room or the front part of the
room when i'm virtual i train myself to
look at the camera as i'm speaking
because as i look at the camera it looks
like i'm looking at you rather than
looking down at all of your images that
i see on the screen and thank you to
those of you showing your video
so we want to make eye contact
and then finally when it comes to
nonverbal presence we have to think
about our voice
your voice is a wind instrument just
like a trumpet a clarinet a saxophone
the more air you put through it the more
you can do with it
we need to vary our voice
our brains are wired to habituate
anything that stays the same we stop
paying attention to
so you need to vary your voice to keep
people involved and engaged
now for some of us that's hard we speak
in a more monotone mono-rate way
a great tool to help you have more
variation in your voice is to insert
emotive words adjectives and adverbs if
you need some help come back to campus
we have this lovely adverb wall some of
you have seen it on the campus
insert some of those adverbs into what
you say
i would never come to you and say i'm
really excited to be here
no i would say i'm really excited to be
here those emotive words invite and
invoke that variation in my voice
so to answer the question what comes
after minimally viable communication and
you have your message crafted and honed
and dialed in for maximal value you then
have to think about the channel through
which you will push that message out
and then how do you deliver it in terms
of your nonverbal presence big balanced
and still
make eye contact if you're in north
american culture
and vary your voice
that was a long-winded answer but
hopefully helpful to thinking about what
comes next after this process we talked
about today
perfect yes and actually you answered
another question that had said asked for
some tips when it came to virtual
communication so i think that can i add
a couple more though if somebody wants
to know something let me share a couple
other tips about non-verbal about
virtual communication this is something
that we have all had to learn a lot
about and interestingly some new
exciting research is coming out to help
us
a couple things
one you want to make sure that you fill
half your screen
many of us as i alluded to earlier stand
really far away from our cameras we are
wired to pay attention to people's faces
we read a lot of information off
people's faces and if we can't see
somebody's face we feel uncomfortable so
fill your screen with half your your
body so
half the screen should be you
second
make sure that you are well lit
again if we want to see people's faces
we have to be able to see you
many people
look like they are in the witness
protection program when they do virtual
presenting they're in the dark they're
in the shadows
light things up and it doesn't have to
cost a lot of money i mean you can t if
you talk to any teenager ask them about
tick tock and ring lights and they'll
they'll wax poetic and they'll tell you
how you can get these different lights
to light up but you can actually just
run down to a hardware store get some
mechanics lights the kind of lights a
mechanic would clip to your hood to look
at your engine and that will work just
as well
another thing is raise your camera up so
it's eye level with you many of you when
we do when many of us when we do virtual
communication we use laptops and the
laptop typically sits lower than we are
so the angle is up under our chin
nobody looks good from this angle in
fact when i was a kid if we wanted to
scare people at night we would shine a
flashlight underneath our chin to look
scary that's how some people look get a
book a box a stand raise your your
laptop or your camera up so it's eye
level with you
and then the last bit of advice is many
of these tools zoom meet webex etc teams
they have recording capabilities record
yourself practicing and watch it it is
incredibly painful to watch ourselves
we make all of our mba students do it in
our strategic communication classes they
have to record and watch themselves it
is yet the single best teacher
to see how you are communicating so
make sure you can be seen raise your
camera get some good lighting and record
yourself that's going to help you be a
better virtual communicator
so our next question is how has social
media facebook twitter tick tock changed
your concepts do you expect more changes
in the near future wow this there's a
lot that could be said here so different
modalities of communication have clearly
affected how we do strategic
communication within organizations for
sure
and the
one how ubiquitous they are but also how
quickly you can put messages out there
really necessitates this minimally
viable communication approach there will
be times where you just have to get
messages out quickly and you can use
these social media tools as a way of
testing your messages and as a
the end point of the process as well
we spend a lot of time in our strategic
communication classes talking about
what's the appropriate channel for the
message you're trying to get across and
often these different types of social
media and the other communication tools
slack etc need to be considered as
viable channels so we have to think
about
what does the channel bring to the
way in which we craft the message if
you're on twitter you have you have
constraints how many words you can use
you have to think about it it does the
message make better sense to have visual
if you're using instagram for example uh
so it requires you to bring in other
questions in the design process
what do i foresee coming
forward
more and more
types of social channels for us to
communicate in i don't know how many of
you are aware of something like a
clubhouse or other things where it's an
audio only social media platform we're
going to see more and more opportunities
for us to communicate and other tools
and we have to think about our messaging
and make sure that our messaging is
specific and tailored to the different
channels again
the context piece and that process i
went through
for minimally viable communication is
really about considering those elements
of the channel so i'm excited by it i
think it's fascinating i love teaching
folks who are younger than i am i learn
a lot about different ways of
communicating and we all have to embrace
these different channels
clearly there are liabilities involved
we have to think about it there are
ethics involved you need only look at
the the the news to see issues around
social media but they are channels for
getting our messages out and we have to
explore and in some cases exploit them
you may have already answered this by
mentioning practice iteration watching
your recordings as embarrassing as that
might be
but how do you train students to speak
with more confidence
um
yeah so confidence is something i've
spent a lot of my career focused on it's
it's research i did all the way back in
undergrad and grad school it is critical
to
focus on confidence confidence is the
biggest barrier to people sharing their
opinions and voices and i firmly believe
we need to hear from as many people as
possible in our our
dialogue to understand and be better at
what we do so to my mind confidence is
really about focusing on two issues one
is the symptoms that happen to us
physiologically and mentally when we get
nervous in our communication and then
looking at some of the sources
of anxiety and i invite you to check out
not only that book i wrote or the
website no freaking speaking to see lots
of my thoughts and thoughts of others on
this but let me give you just two quick
examples one in each
camp the symptoms and the sources to
help build confidence
when it comes to symptoms our body is
invoking the fight-or-flight response to
our communication
i believe in others who study this that
there's an evolutionary component to why
we get nervous
our bodies experience speaking in front
of others as a threat and responds in
kind and i'm happy if we have time later
in this session or in other ways to go
more into that
perspective why we see it as a threat
but as a result of that threat we invoke
fight or flight our heart rate elevates
we
begin breathing more shallow
a lot of adrenaline is pumped which
causes us to shake and perspire etc
the single best thing you can do to
short-circuit the fight-or-flight
response invoked through your anxiety
around communication is deep breathing
deep belly breaths can calm down and
slow down your autonomic nervous system
now i recently learned and this is i i
love doing the think fast talk smart
podcast because i learned so much i had
a
cognitive neuroscientist here at
stanford his name is andrew huberman
super bright guy if you ever get a
chance check out his work he was a guest
on the podcast and we were talking about
stress and how to reduce stress
and i said well everybody says deep
breathing helps is that true he goes
absolutely but it's not the inhale
and that rocked my world for years
decades i've been telling people take a
deep inhale a deep breath it's not the
inhale that helps you relax it's
actually the exhale
so the rule of thumb or shall i say the
rule of lung is this to use deep breath
to calm yourself down you want your
exhale to be twice as long as your
inhale and again if we have extra time
now or later or you can just listen to
the podcast you'll learn why this is but
if you take a slow three count in to
calm yourself down make sure that your
exhale is six count and you only have to
do it two or three times to actually
take the benefit so to manage symptoms
probably the best thing you can do deep
breath focus on the exhalation
from a symptoms point of view from a
source's point of view the things that
actually make us nervous there's a lot
that we can focus on
some of you might have heard me uh
deliver a talk that i did at a reunion
several years ago now called think fast
talk smart the name of the podcast came
from that talk
where i talk about one source of anxiety
which has to do with the fact that many
of us are made nervous by the goals
we're trying to achieve
whenever you communicate you have a goal
in fact i encouraged you to create a
goal and many of us can be made nervous
by the thought of not achieving that
goal
so we begin to get nervous about a
potential negative future outcome i'm
not going to get the good grade i'm not
going to get the funding i'm not going
to get the support we're worried about
not achieving our goal
that's the source of the anxiety a way
to mitigate that source to reduce the
impact of that negative potential future
outcome is to become present oriented
and in that video i talk a lot in that
talk i talk a lot about what you can do
to become president-oriented for example
do something physical take a walk
do some exercise listen to a song or a
playlist or the one that i like to
encourage people to do is to start at
the number 100 and count backwards by a
challenging number like 13s or 17s
all of those activities bring you into
the present moment which distract you
from worrying about a future consequence
so how do you get more confident you
tackle both your symptoms and your
sources and there's a lot more i could
say about that but those are examples i
give you one example of how to manage a
symptom by deep breathing and how to
manage a source trying to become present
oriented long-winded answer but a really
important issue
if you are doing a presentation for
which there is a somewhat standardized
set of expectations for the format or
the context content so for example the
startup team is pitching a potential
investor
to adopt your approach
yeah so so there are often situations
where there are expectations for the
structure of the communication like an
investor pitch or you're presenting your
research or your findings there are
often expectations around the structure
of the message
yet the content that goes into that
message i think would benefit very
directly from what we talked about in
terms of minimally viable
design so the structure might be set so
for example in a pitch deck there's an
expectation that you'll start by talking
about the problem you'll introduce your
team you'll talk about the the total
addressable market etc
but how you approach that what what you
say about that market or how you define
and frame the problem all of that can be
rapidly prototyped and tested to figure
out the best way for this particular
audience so i i think that those
structures can actually be helpful you
know going into a pitch where the person
says in your pitch you must do these
seven things that's wonderfully helpful
that's very insightful information about
here the person is telling me how they
want to hear my message they're telling
me how to structure it great now i'm
going to iterate as best i can to figure
out for each one of those identified
steps slides or parts of the
presentation how can i maximize the
value of what i say for each of those
steps so i actually think
the structure given can be very helpful
to the process we walked out we walked
through
this may be related to that but is the
call to action component required and
the example given here is that uh our
alum is a volunteer uh in the national
park
he likes to import knowledge and perhaps
some emotion but he feels it might be a
little too preachy when he gives a
action so any anything
first thank you for the work you do in
the national parks i and my family have
benefited from from and have enjoyed
going uh and learning from the people
who are there so thank you for that work
you don't always have to have a call to
action i would like for you though to
consider should i have a call to action
what are the advantages and
disadvantages of doing that and then
make a judgment call so i i share in the
process i i introduced the idea of where
you would put one the now what but you
don't always have to invoke it again you
know your audience you know you're who
you are and what it works best for you
but i would like you to consider what
would a call to action
sound like and there are calls to action
that are less directive and less preachy
it could simply be thank you for your
time and for showing your passion for
nature and the environment and i
encourage you to
keep focus on the environment it's very
important that's a very soft way of
giving a call to action so again it's
not always required i do think it's
important to think should i and if i
were to do that what would it sound like
and what are the advantages and
disadvantages of doing so
perfect
a couple of quick setup questions yes
thoughts standing versus sitting
what do you what do you choose i choose
standing uh i'm standing now i i stand
for two reasons one it helps me focus
when i sit i get distracted more easily
and two standing allows me to use my
full body more it allows me to to be
taller so i can get more air into my
lungs and i find that it helps me with
what i call vocal stamina the ability to
to speak for long periods of time
if you stand though i recommend a couple
things one you want to make sure that
you know sway and rock and lean so it
comes down to your foot position you
want your feet to be parallel underneath
your shoulders if your feet are splayed
out like a penguin or a duck which is
how many of us stand it opens up your
hips and it invites this swaying which
is very distracting if you know you do
sway and rock a bit when you present
standing and you're doing it virtually
get a stool or a box or a book put one
foot up on it there is no way you will
sway a rock if you have one foot up on a
stool you'll literally fall over if you
try
so i like to stand and what else if you
sit that's fine the big thing about
sitting is you want to make sure you you
are in a chair that is either locked
down or cannot swivel or rock because
many of us will sway or swivel and many
chairs have arm rests and when you're
sitting you look like you're a robot
because your your hands are just
naturally placed here so remove or lower
those armrests so you can use your arms
more naturally
creighton what are your thoughts on one
camera multiple cameras
so uh i am a simpleton uh i it is very
hard for me to deal with just one camera
if you are in a situation where you have
assistance and help then multiple
cameras might be interesting again it's
novel it can change things up and change
perspectives
it's hard to manage i thought what you
were going to ask not one or two cameras
i thought you were going to say one or
two screens
and i have a different opinion on
screens i do think having multiple
screens can be helpful today i have two
screens that i'm able to manage and
watch
that allow me to keep track of where my
presentation is and where you are in
terms of how you're you're moving
through it so um screens are different
you do need to practice and and get
comfortable with them
but i i i myself use multiple screens
and only one camera
thank you so much matt in the last
couple of minutes i would like to ask
you if you have any good recommendations
uh books or resources around increasing
confidence when speaking and also is
there a way for us or companies to
engage you as a coach or a consultant
well thank you for all those questions
so
i do believe the speaking up without
freaking out book is a book that can be
very helpful to people who want to
become better communicators especially
building confidence
the book was written for that the book
was written for stanford mba students in
mind so those of you who have been here
or are here hopefully can benefit from
that
the book i mentioned earlier when i
talked about the the don't mess with
texas ad made to stick i think is a
wonderful book around communication
skills and could be very helpful
there are lots of
videos and resources
out there to to help i've tried to
curate a lot of those on the no
freak no
freaking speaking site uh in terms of
reaching out to me i am very happy to
help alum and and students in any way i
can
my email address can be found on the the
gsb faculty website uh it's also here
i'll put up my my screen again so you
can you can see my email address
but i'm very happy to reach out i
co-founded a consulting practice called
bold echo we do this work out in the in
the corporate world if that can be of
help i really just encourage all of you
to focus on your communication
communication is critical we saw through
the pandemic how communication can be
incredibly
important to keeping our businesses
connected and thriving and our personal
lives connected and thriving and i hope
minimally viable communication that
approach can help you hone your
communication so thank you for listening
and if i can be of service please let me
know